[Music]
tritium
it's that mysterious glowing element
found in air water and now inside you
yeah that's right you're going to take
this radioactive isotope and
chug it down
bottoms up
so if you drank tritium how could your
body power a nuclear reactor
what would happen to your dna
and
would you glow in the dark
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you drank radioactive tritium
so what the heck is tritium anyway
well simply put it's the radioactive
form of hydrogen
the hydrogen with two extra neutrons to
be exact
and
that combination
makes it unstable
it can be found in either a gas or
liquid form
for our experiment we'll be dealing with
the liquid
it's in the atmosphere when cosmic rays
hit gases floating up there but you
don't need to look up to find it it's
right here on the ground
manufacturers mix tritium gas with a
little bit of phosphor to create a
self-luminous light source that doesn't
need electricity
that makes it perfect for exit signs and
emergency lighting
but if this isotope entered your body
how long would it take to get it out
[Music]
tritium emits beta radiation meaning it
gives off energy as it decays typically
its weak particles aren't strong enough
to penetrate the skin so it wouldn't be
your skin glowing but we'll dive further
into that later
doctors often use small amounts of
tritium to trace chemical compounds in
the human body but you in all your
wisdom are gulping down four and a half
liters of this stuff
so what happens next
well once you consume this isotope it
goes right through your bloodstream via
your gastrointestinal tract
minutes later it would be in your organs
and your tissue and in less than two
hours the tritium would contaminate all
of your body fluids
a study published by the international
atomic energy agency found that 56
of rats drinking tritium-laced water
developed tumors within 18 months
and considering how much you just drank
maybe that would be your fate
even if you guzzled less than a few
liters it would take a month to pee out
all the tritium
beta particles the radioactive element
in tritium have low energy and wouldn't
be able to travel far throughout your
body
sounds good right
these particles would clump together in
certain places in your body creating
radioactive hot spots
these small areas would be bombarded
with radiation
so would those areas give off a less
than healthy glow
well remember tritium needs phosphorus
to light up so overeating phosphorus
rich food like meat eggs and some dairy
products could start a chemical reaction
your stomach could light up like a glow
stick
and that light would be absorbed in all
the surrounding tissue
but this isn't a party trick you want to
do often
these photons contain such a high amount
of energy that they could alter your dna
permanently
but now that tritium is coursing through
your system
would you be able to generate power
well again since tritium breaks down
over time some companies have developed
tritium batteries that can last more
than 20 years
but even though you might be a walking
nightlight
it wouldn't work that way
the radiation emitting from the decaying
tritium would have to hit a
semiconductor to carry an electrical
charge yeah well that's a relief
but even if you haven't downed liters of
tritium
is there a chance it's already inside
you
well
maybe
if you live near a nuclear reactor
as i said tritium is the byproduct of
nuclear reactors and while it can be
separated from water
the process is costly so many power
plants don't consider it an extra step
worth taking since the material
eventually breaks down
even the infamous fukushima plant in
japan will discharge its treated water
beginning in 2023
in florida scientists studying a nuclear
power plant found an elevated tritium
concentration in the drinking water
now while those levels were still below
epa standards they were up to
215 times that of the background level
of radiation
[Music]
but hey since you're in the mood to
drink something toxic
let's double down
what if i gave you a glass of water from
lake natron
well
pinch your nose and chug it back because
that's a story
or another what if